oui matthieu delormeau voulait dire
quelque chose du bonheur oui juste un
mot là c'est pas sur les écoles mais sur
le concret pour le docteur a - et
mohamed ces 18 mois à peine c'est
qu'effectivement on nous dit que le kobe
tu peux dire a encore jusqu'à janvier
février ça va encore mais et que le
retour à la vie seront ça sera un retour
il faudra faire attention avec des
mesures mais quand on est très concret
comme moelle de temps en temps
descendent dans la rue fin des courses
vivre avec un masque ou le porter c'est
un enfer il fait chaud on n'est pas bien
là dedans ça craque et tout est ce que
ça veut dire que concrètement se laver
les mains c'est bien mais concrètement
va devoir s'habituer tous à vivre avec
un masque au moins jusqu'en janvier
oui jean paul hamon n'en sais rien on
n'en sait rien vous savez c'est un c'est
un virus qu'on découvre tous les jours
mais si vous voyez par exemple ce qui se
passe en corée au japon etc où il ya de
la différenciation sociale naturelle où
les gens portent des masses et compagnie
bon c'est vrai que ce soit ce sera un
vrai changement
on sait pas du tout de quoi sera fait la
vie au mois de septembre
honnêtement on n'en sait rien si une
faut qu'on apprenne à vivre avec ce
virus est pour atteindre une vaccination
collective il faudrait que j'y ai 60 %
des personnes qui qui les attraper et
donc ça pour le moment les legends
objectif les gens optimistes disent
comme le ministre disons le co 10 % des
français sont simulés on est loin on est
loin des 60 % alors c'est sûr qu'il va
falloir apprendre à vivre à vivre avec
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir protéger
vraiment les anciens il va falloir
trouver quand même quelque chose
d'intelligent pour que les anciens ne
soient pas coupés de leurs familles et
et ça c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu angoissant de bon le
président a fixé le 11 mai on sait très
bien tous ici que le 11 mai rien rien ne
sera finie donc comment déjà on a
commencé à changer de vie on a vu des
gens dtt s'orchestre des des chanteurs
nous faire d d d d d d deschamps
absolument formidable chacun chez soi et
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que bon va
falloir être inventifs pour rester
optimiste